so when we think about democracy I think
there's kind of a real interesting
opportunity to think about what is
participatory democracy in the modern
connected connected world and I think
there's all kinds of versions that are
much better than the vote every two year
kind of version that we have right now
for example there's a lovely experiment
that said what if people got to vote on
were five percent of their income tax
goes to so you would get a list of all
the things the government does right
which is actually it's already a good
thing because people don't know what the
government does we went at some point we
went to the Chapel Hill Public Library
and we asked people when was the last
time you got benefit from taxpayers
money people couldn't remember when was
the last time and they were in a public
library funded by taxpayers money so you
know we don't really understand what the
government does what what taxes go for
but if you got a list of all the things
the government does and you could decide
five percent you know you probably don't
want people to allocate all of their
income tax because there's some things
that the government needs to worry about
but doing some kind of marginal
contribution and thinking where we want
to be I think would get people to be
more involved care more look at waste I
think will make government officers a
bit more accountable so that's one
version where I think we could get
participatory democracy to be closer to
what we want it want it to be and
another another kind of direction is to
say why do we need to vote for one
person so so imagine that we would have
a voting procedure which would say you
could say I won't Dan then really to
vote for me on any issues that has to do
with education and health but not about
I don't know space exploration and not
about nuclear activities imagine all of
society is a network of people and you
can assign your vote not
just to the representatives but you
could assign your votes to other people
in society well you could say you know
what then I trust you on those topics
you could vote for me and I could trust
somebody else and so on so we could we
could create a network in which we trust
different people for different subtopics
and not have this idea that is one
person who is representing us is is the
right person for all all topics around
so so that's one the other the other of
course a big issue and I don't know if
you saw this but we we did a lot of
studies about how people want society to
be designed so originally we did it from
inequality financial inequality but then
we moved to other areas as well but in
the area of financial inequality and we
asked people first of all what they
understand about the distribution of
wealth in the US so we said imagine if
we took all the people in the u.s. from
the poorest to the richest we broke them
into five buckets the 20% richest 20%
less less less in the poorest and we
asked you from the hundred percent
wealth tone pie how much is allocated
right now to each of those five buckets
and people think that the bottom two
buckets the bottom forty percent of
Americans own about nine percent of the
wealth where in fact they own about 0.3
right so the this slope is what's called
the Gini coefficient the rate of
inequality people know the rich have a
lot of people don't understand Americans
understand how little the poor the poor
have and then we also asked them what
would you like society to be and we use
John Rawls if you remember John Rawls
had this interesting idea that he said a
just society there's a society that if
you know everything about it you would
be willing to join it in a random place
but if you're very rich you might want
society that treats the rich nice and
the poor not so nice if you're very poor
you might want the other way around but
if you don't know where you'll be you'll
be allocated after the fact you have to
consider out
effective and it called is the veil of
ignorance because you choose before you
know where where you'll be so we
describe the veil of ignorance to lots
of people and we say what kind of
society would you like to create and
Americans created a society that is more
equal than Sweden not perfectly equals
nobody wants socialism but much more
equal than in Sweden and not only that
the differences between Republicans and
Democrats were tiny so you know
Republicans won in slightly more
inequality Democrats were in slightly
more equality but it was small
difference compared to the gap between
what we have and what people want and
that's another way to think about
democracy in the modern world so you
know you could say that we could vote on
a topic like we could vote on whether we
want Obama's health care version that's
that's one approach but but to vote on
that as individual this way to complex
this plan is I mean includes so much
we're not going to be experts on it we
don't have the time to really read there
whatever 7,000 pages of this plan what
what we could do is we could vote on our
principles on how we want society to be
right not about the concrete aspect but
on what what are they the guiding
principles of a society how much we care
about equality and how much we care
about access to health and not to vote
on something concrete but to vote on it
in terms of what are the principles we
believe in and then it will be the job
of the politicians to take our
principles and translate them into
policies think about something like
investment if you go to an investment
professional to help you they don't ask
you what stocks you want to invest in
that's their job what they ask you is
what can I first you want to take how
much money do you want to give to
charity they ask you one of the general
principles about life and then they go
ahead and figure how those principles
are going to be played out in the
details and and that's another kind of I
think interesting version to think about
politics which you say we as citizens
will never have the expertise to truly
vote on everything
but we understand their own values and
we can say what kind of society do we
want to to create and it'll be the job
of the politicians to take these values
and translate them into specific
instances and rules
you